بدأنا caitlin كولينز cnn من caitlyn ،
ما الذي تتعلمه عن عملية fbi هذه ،
إنه تطور رائع حيث
أكد الرئيس السابق نفسه
أن مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي قد نفذ
أمر تفتيش في منزله في شاطئ النخيل في
فلوريدا اليوم ، قال في بيان
إنه جميل  منزل mar-a-lago في
شاطئ النخيل بالطبع الذي أصبح
مقر إقامته الرئيسي بعد خروجه من
البيت الأبيض وهو حاليًا تحت الحصار
ويحتل من قبل عدد كبير من
عملاء مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي كما يقول بعد العمل
والتعاون مع الجهات الحكومية ذات الصلة في
هذه المداهمة المفاجئة  في
منزلي لم يكن ضروريًا أو مناسبًا
، يضيف جون اقتباسًا حتى أنهم
اقتحموا خزنتي وقارن ذلك بـ
Watergate عكس Watergate
وأكد أنه محاولة لمنعه
من الترشح للرئاسة في عام 2024
بالطبع يجب أن نلاحظ أننا
تعلمنا الآن ذلك
مذكرة التفتيش هذه تتعلق
بالتحقيق في كيفية
تعامل الرئيس السابق مع المعلومات السرية المحتملة
معلومات حساسة بالتأكيد عندما غادر البيت الأبيض ،
وهو أمر عرفناه بالفعل
أنه قد أخذ معه حوالي 15
صندوقًا إلى مار أ لاغو عندما
غادر البيت الأبيض في يناير من عام 2021 ،
فقد تأخروا في إعادة تلك الصناديق
إلى  الأرشيفات الوطنية التي
أرادوها وكنا نعلم أن هذا كان قيد
التحقيق لأنه كان هناك في
الواقع أمر استدعاء تم إصداره إلى
الأرشيف الوطني نفسه لما ورد
في هذه الوثائق ، أرادوا معرفة
ما كان بداخلهم من الذي وضعهم في حزم ومن
أخذهم شخصيًا  إلى mar-a-lago ،
فقد كانت هذه أسئلة رئيسية
حول هذا الأمر ، لكن هذا
تصعيد كبير لعملاء مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي هؤلاء للذهاب
وتنفيذ أمر تفتيش في
المقر الرئيسي للرئيس السابق ،
وسأشير إلى جون أن
وزارة العدل لا تعلق الليلة عندما
cnn تواصلت مع البيت الأبيض في بايدن
ولم يكن على علم بأن هذا كان
يجري ويقولون إنهم اكتشفوا
عندما فعل البقية منا ما فعلته  عندما
أكد الرئيس السابق هذا ،
أود أيضًا أن أشير إلى أن ترامب لم يكن حاضرًا
في مار أ لاغو عندما حدث هذا ، فهو
في برج ترامب في نيويورك ، لم يكن
موجودًا في بيدمينستر أو أعذرني في
شاطئ النخيل حيث لا يفعل ذلك في كثير من الأحيان  يقضي
الصيف بشكل واضح على الرغم من أن الرئيس
الرئيس السابق غير سعيد جدًا
بهذا الأمر ويقول إنه يعتقد أن
الدافع كان سياسيًا لأننا كنا
ننتظر معرفة المزيد حول ما كان وراء ذلك بالضبط.